playing season is in full blast and we
hear of any tuber dedicated to giving
you the best in the world of anime so
what's hot and buzzing in the jam-packed
season without further Ado here are my
picks for the top spring 2023 anime I'm
going to be featuring new anime here so
in case you still haven't chosen a show
to pick up this list might help you set
your sights on something I got a cheat
skill in another world makes a nice
opening don't you think
I look
it's a tale as old as time and it's a
guy somehow tries to make a splash by
attaching itself to a unique gimmick
promising something that you've never
seen before or something you haven't
seen as much of I've got a cheat skill
attempts to do that with how it marketed
itself as a pseudo isakai while it has
all the makings of an isakai it tries to
build its premise around having the
isakai powers and settings applied in
the real world well as for the actual
result I think it's middle of the pack
and that's why it's only a number 10.
inspire me generally enjoying it for
what it is I do think some parts and
developments were pretty rushed but if
you're already a fan of these kinds of
issakai then it shouldn't be anything
new to you you can just sit back and let
the show take its course it's not
exactly a groundbreaking show in spite
of the seemingly unique premise but his
popcorn entertainment it does do its job
pretty well it's cool and a lot of times
that's just what one needs when picking
up an anime to watch
at number nine we have my home hero
[Music]
my home hero I feel is a show that does
draw a lot of interest it's got a good
premise and from the get-go it quickly
reels you in with a conflict and you
can't seem to wait to develop and if
you're talking about the premise and how
they handled it I think that my home
hero does a pretty decent job at it like
the previous entry it's not exactly a
groundbreaking addition to the series
but if you're looking for something to
this effect to watch the whole crime and
suspense story then this could be an
enjoyable watch for you my home hero
sits here in the ninth spot mainly
because the production values need some
work maybe it would just spoiled with
awesome art and animation these days but
for a story that draws as much Intrigue
as my home hero it deserves some more
love and care in its adaptation that
doesn't make or break the show however
and I still have it as one of my 10
favorites from this season
the number eight spot belongs to my love
story with yamadakun at level 999.
oh
now here's a show that's absent from my
pre-season previews I do think that I
have overlooked this show a bit you know
upon checking it out I think it's a fun
show to watch at first glance it's easy
if you're a veteran Watcher to be
reminded of the show recovery of an MMO
junkie or something like Walter koi
since that's more popular regardless
there's always a spot in my heart for
rom-coms like there's a deal with the
aspect of social interactions from the
perspective of a huge gamer or geek the
show does have a little bit of
everything that you want from a rom-com
lovable characters that have good
chemistry with one another an ample dose
of comedy and some surprisingly
important lessons to be learned some
people have compared into horimia and I
can really see where they're coming from
I didn't talk about the show in my
previews before but if you're looking
for a light-hearted rom-com to watch
this season then make sure to check this
one out gamer or not you'll definitely
find something to enjoy in it
is that
dead Mount death play is up next
foreign
on the other hand I talked plenty about
this show in my previews being a fan of
Devon is a part-timer I've always been
out for a sort of retread in that
direction only this time a much darker
take in terms of atmosphere with a
slightly more pronounced Dash on realism
I really love The Source material and I
think that the anime did a good job at
translating that experience of reading
the source material into animated form I
gotta say that the fight scenes
impressed me and they do well in putting
someone in as early as the first episode
so far it's been great at creating
Intrigue creating that kind of drama
that keeps you watching as it pulls
Cliffhanger after Cliffhanger on you I
mean yeah at times it does try to take
things in a more light-hearted Direction
a decision that might not sit well to
those who really came for the dark
atmosphere but overall it's still an
enjoyable watch it's one that I'll
recommend this season and unless you're
someone who absolutely dislikes a show
with a grim atmosphere and this is one
that you're going to want to check out
[Music]
insomniacs after school comes in in the
sixth slot on the list
[Music]
now if you haven't watched insomniacs
after school the main keyword I can give
you is relaxing there's just something
really warm and cozy about this Slice of
Life anime which feels almost ironic
considering the premise your mileage may
vary but warm and relaxing are things
that you also don't typically associate
with the Embrace of the night but those
that will accurately describe the
dialogue and relationship between our
main leads here insomniac's after school
is overall a simple Story a tale of two
leads bonding over their shared dilemma
and growing with each other's help it's
a romance where the main characters are
very likable and that I think is one of
the most important elements of a
character-based work like this there's
not a lot of convoluted love triangles
or melodrama for this show and they are
just elevates the appeal of the title so
much this is my pick if you prefer a
more sweet and relaxing romance as
compared to the comedic hijinks of
yamadakon which I discussed not too long
ago
[Music]
foreign
and if you're liking the stuff you've
seen so far how about spending a few
seconds in hitting that like button up
there it helps the channel and this
video a lot and I'd really appreciate
your contribution in letting the channel
grow thanks a bunch let's get back to
the list next up is Marshall
foreign
punch man has found a new successor it
would see when it takes place in a magic
Academy that's a pretty simple premise
and it speaks volumes about the show
this is basically the plot
straightforward as it is but that
doesn't make it any less entertaining
there's something really Charming about
the satirical overpowered protagonist
shows that make them so lovable despite
seeing them in many permutations at this
point a very notable one which is Misfit
of Demon King Academy on the contrary
Marshall goes all in on the gags and
comedic aspects of it letting it take
the front and center role of it all in
contrast to Misfit and it works to its
favor for someone raring to see
something with the same Vibes as one
punch man Marshall comes in as a
pleasant treat it's pretty evident that
the show also takes some inspiration in
cues from Black Clover and Harry Potter
and I think that added a bit to the
enjoyment of it all who doesn't love an
Underdog Story getting flipped on its
Heels by starring a protagonist who's
actually secret op after all
foreign
to wrap things up pretty nicely skip to
loafer is a show that in more ways can
be relatable to the youth especially in
this bustling and ever-changing society
that we live in moving out into a new
adventure and being the proverbial fish
out of water does bring forth a lot of
challenges and I'm sure that a lot of us
find ourselves in the shoes of mitsumi
iwakura skip to loafer overall it's one
of those charming school dramas you see
every once in a while with characters
that you can't help but love and an
overall positive and welcoming tone it
takes things slowly but never feels
boring once you get the hang of the
characters in the world they live in and
I myself find it a breath of fresh air
especially considering how a live shows
seem to try to craft up a very deep plot
or a lot of forced darkness in order to
catch the attention of the fans having a
nice relaxing and wholesome show like
this is actually quite a lot of fun a
good partner for insomniacs after school
if you decide to pick up that one
opening the top three is Heavenly
delusion
this is a show that I feel got
overlooked by many during the pre-season
I haven't seen too much hype on it and
one I won't call this a niche show by
any means I think we can very well call
this the sleeper heat of the Season
Heavenly delusion quickly places itself
in the position to be compared to a show
with a similar premise promise Neverland
in contrast to the horror emphasis of
the latter Heavenly delusion seems to
lean more towards the mystery survival
aspects of the similar premise sure it's
got some controversial aspects but with
how good it is in terms of everything
else like the dialogue and the World
building it's a show that I'd heartily
recommend to most people are for some
mature anime it's certainly one of the
more intriguing hits this season
in second place is Hell's Paradise
foreign
[Music]
hell's Paradise is a show that I did
have high expectations for heading into
the season and I'm pleased to say that
those expectations have been met I've
raved about the whole dark serious
Adventure feel and the action but with
the anime adaptation I've also really
liked how they translated the main
themes as largely helped by the very
eye-catching visuals and sound Direction
the characters also have a lot of
interesting backstories and their
overall development will surely
Captivate any fan who took even the
slightest liking to the Plucky crew the
whole show is a great example of how
atmosphere and the character types go
hand in hand to create an anime that
will grab your attention with an eye ink
rib of course most people watch it for
the action and adventure but it's also
got some interesting things to say about
the idea of life and death if you're to
ask me a strong meaningful themes like
that is the icing to the cake for me
very very fulfilling icing on my ad
[Music]
standing atop the rankings is none other
than oshinoko
it's brilliant these guys did it I
already had high hopes for the show and
I knew it was going to be a massive hit
but to be this big of a hit it kind of
caught me off guard I got to give some
props to the genius play of making the
first episode movie length and then
quickly hooking people into the mystery
with one hell of a cliffhanger the
mystery is awesome but I do think that
the characters also do such a great job
in helping carry the show to make it a
complete package it's a show that caught
quite a lot of anime ownies off guard
and with this sudden dark turn and
subsequent serious tone it's definitely
a show that people who previously
haven't appreciated anime can learn to
love that's not to say that the show is
completely Grim dark it balances the
more light-hearted and staple moments
with the serious social commentary bits
really well giving itself a chance to
hook fans from various ends of the
spectrum it's too early to be crowning
oshinoko anime of the year but it's a
serious contender in that regard I truly
recommend this show if you haven't
checked it out already
and those are my picks for top 10 anime
of spring 2023 is my list looking like
yours feel free to share your thoughts
in the comments Down Below in case you
want to check out the other lists and
videos head on over to my channel and
find something to your fancy as usual
like And subscribe and I hope you
enjoyed watching the video looking
forward to seeing you next time